direction les Internationaux de tennis
de Blois Kiss poursuivent jusqu'à samedi
au complexe du Puy Cuisy sur place des
joueurs français et étrangers tous
classés à l'ATP qui enchaîne les matchs
sur les cours extérieurs en terre battue
le petit Roland-Garros du Loir-et-Cher
continue de fonctionner grâce à son
armada de bénévoles c'est ce que nous
confirmerons aux mains d'Elvin
Riddick
sont deux tennis menindiens qui découvre
le circuit européen des tournois en
Serbie après Rennes et Quimper en indoor
et cette semaine les terrains en terre
battu de la giblois
ce type de tournoi doit m'aider à monter
dans le classement ATP c'est le but
c'est la première année que je participe
à des tournois challenger en Europe
passé challenger en 2013 le deuxième
niveau mondial le tournoi de Blois tient
son rang grâce à l'appui des partenaires
des collectivités et la volonté voir la
ténacité d'un homme Claude Roger le
directeur et de son équipe et ce n'est
pas évident quand tout est régi par
l'inflation a commencé par la dotation
du tournoi passé de 46 000 à 75000 euros
les installations qu'on fait et qui ne
dure que huit jours les dix jours donc
c'est à dire on coûtait un peu plus cher
le restauration est un peu plus cher que
l'année dernière il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui au pendent donc
dans le prévisionnel de dépenses on
avait prévu à peu près 5% mais
on arrive à 15% d'augmentation il faut
faire face mais je vais dire on va y
arriver et je pense que même c'est
difficile on est quand même très
satisfait de pouvoir faire un beau un
beau tournoi qui est très fort être
tournoi Challenger ce sont aussi des
obligations 52 ramasseurs de balles
issus du collège Marcel Carné de Vineuil
32 juges de ligne et depuis 20 ans une
armée de bénévoles au four et au moulin
au transport des joueurs et à la
restauration Hélène et professeur
d'anglais c'est mercredi et elle vient
donner un coup de main à l'organisation
on est aussi payé comme ça le fait de se
dire que
j'aurais contribué à sa carrière en lui
servant des pâtes
donc oui mais il y a aussi il y a aussi
ce côté là il y a deux trois deux trois
têtes d'affiches qui sont là et on se
dit bah ceux-là ils vont peut-être aller
loin dans les classements c'est
peut-être juste le début de leur
carrière et on aura été là véritable
tremplin comme pour rude finaliste à
Roland Garros cette année rune
demi-finaliste aliasim actuel numéro 9
mondial les Internationaux de Blois
veulent garder ce statut de dénicheur de
pépites